- Well, it was certainly a
history making night last night.
- Depuis sa victoire éclatante,
il y a deux semaines, on ne
parle que de lui à Washington.
(en anglais)
(en espagnol)
Maxwell Frost est partout
et il sait y faire.
- The first thing I say is
I think we need younger people
in our government.
- Ce jeune politicien
d'Orlando n'a que 25 ans
et, en janvier prochain,
il entrera officiellement
à la Chambre des représentants.
- He will be the youngest
member of Congress.
- Devenant ainsi le premier
représentant de la génératZZZ
élu au Congrès.
Un Congrès dont la moyenne
d'âge est d'environ 58 ans.
- My name is Maxwell
Alejandro Frost!
- Sa campagne, il mememenée sur
les thèmes qui lui sont chers :
les jeunes en politique...
(cris et applaudissements)
... et, bien sûr,
le contrôle des armes à feu,
des armes qu'il ne connaît
malhusususement que trop bien.
(applaudissements)
Mais qui est Maxwell Frost?
Il est d'abord et avant tout
unicicicien.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un percussionniste de talent
qui a commencé très jeune...
♪ ♪ ♪
... et qui a entretenu cet art,
se perfectionnant
année après année.
♪ ♪ ♪
Son père, Patrick Frost,
igigiginaire du Kansas, y est
évidemment pour quelque chose.
- So hear the drums, Max...
(batterie)
Sounds great!
- À tel point qu'il a
même produit un disque
avec le premier groupe
de Maxwell, The Charter.
Maxwell est la fierté
de la famille. Né d'un père
haïtien et d'une mère originaire
de Porto Rico, Iététété donné
en adoption dès sa naissance
à Patrick Frost et sa femme,
d'origine cubaine.
Très jeune il a remporté
des concours de discours
et son talent musical
l'a probablement aidé.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est d'ailleurs à l'école
de musique d'Orlando qu'il a
rencontré un de ses amis
les plus proches, Ivan Garcia,
un musicien de carrière
qui n'est pas surpris
de voir son grand ami
devenir membre du Congrès.
♪ ♪ ♪
Déjà un potentiel futur
président des États-Unis?
En tout cas, il a un modèle.
Il fascine sur la scène
politique et attire déjà
l'attention de Joe Biden,
qui le voit, un jour
peut-être, comme son égal.
Face à cette pression sur
les épaules pour son futur,
Maxwell Frost nous sert
une réponse de politicien.
(cris de joie)
Depuis sa victoire,
la vie de Maxwell Frost
a changé du tout au tout.
(cris de joie)
Tout comme celle
de sa famille, aussi.
♪ ♪ ♪
Avec son style et sa musique,
qu'il n'abandonnera jamais,
le Congrès devra dorénavant
composer avec Maxwell Frost
pour les prochaines années